بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على
سيدنا ونبي
نا ومول
ا محمد
ادخله الان
احييكم اجمل تحيه وادعوكم لسماع باقه
جديده من اغنيتكم نرجو محاوله الاتصال في
وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
انا انس بن عبد الله احسب على المادحين
والمسمعين في المغرب من مواليد
1955 بالرباط
الله اكبر الله
انا اعيش في هذا البيت هذا البيت هذا هو
من بيت صوفي بكل بكل
المقاييس
وهو بجانب الضريح السائح
هذا الضريح
دفينه يعد خليفه للشيخ سيدي احمد تجاليد
في نفاس
وطبعا
ما يعيشه الفقراء التجانيون داخل هذا
الضريح السائحي فاحنا نتمتع به في هذا
الدار حتى ان طبيخ والدتي يشم من ضريح سيد
العربي بن السايح
[موسيقى]
ترى على سماع الذكر
و سماعي
الاذان
وتتويب المؤذنين
وتهلات
تهللت هو اصطلاح على ما يقوم به
المؤذنون او المادحون من سماع
في الصوامع في
زمن معين
هو
قبيله صلاه الصبح وبين المغربين يوم
الخميس
بحيث انه يصعد
المهللون الى
الصوابع ليؤدون هذه المهمه هو نوع من
السماع وهو فن مغربي اصيل
فن
[موسيقى]
يستمد قدسيته من مشروعيته الدينيه فهو ذكر
وصلاه
وسلام
واستغفار
ودعاء ومناجاه
واقبل شهر رمضان
شهر التوبه والغفران شهر العباده والطهر
والايمان
المهللون في رمضان يهللون بوجد
وبخشوع
وتستمع اليه وتستمعوا الى شهقاته وتستمعوا
الى اهاتهم
من خلال تلك الاصوات التي يمجونها
بطبيعه الحال
ومن خلال
انهم يكثرون من الابتهال والدعوات اما في
الايام العاديه فان لهم طقوسا هناك
ينتقلون من السلام على من الصلاه على رسول
الله الى السلام على رسول الله الى تسبيح
الله الى
الابتهال الى غير ذلك يا
عباد
[موسيقى]
هذا وقت
خروم تغل
[موسيقى]
بوا قديما لم يكن هذه الوسائل ديال
الاستماع والتواصل موجوده
وكان الهلال
يحتاج الى قوه صوتيه
لكي يوصل هذا تهللت
ولكن اليوم اصبحت
المسائل متاحه موجود
المكبرات الصوت الى غير ذلك لولا ان
الدوله المغربيه حريصه على
المحافظه على هذه التقاليد الهلال
ياتي في وقتين
يستجاب فيه الدعاء وهو جوف الليل
[موسيقى]
اولا نتاثرت
بتهللت من رجل
يعتبر
صوتا رائعا جدا صوت ملائكي هو من مدينه
زرهون ومولاي عبد السلام شبيه القدوري هذا
الرجل كان يمتلك له براعه كبيره
في في كان يموج
الكنافوره يموج الالحان وله رصيد من
الاجتهادات الصوتيه الرائعه جدا
لقد جاد من
اهوا
[موسيقى]
والمقدم كان يستمع الي من خلال الراديو
وكان عاجزا لا يستطيع الذهاب الى الخامس
فقال قولته الشهيره الحمد لله الذي جعل من
صلبي من يقرا القران ويصلي على رسول الله
اولا للحفاظ على الصوت هناك مساله علميه
اولا انا لا تغني في مقام غير مقابلك
غير مقام الصوت ديالك الشيء الاول
الشيء الثاني
يحتاج الصوت الى الراحه الى النوم
[موسيقى]
يا ارحم الراحمين يا رب العالمين
اللهم اجعلنا من اكبر الصديقين
وعاملنا معامله المحبوبين
[موسيقى]
وقنا شر الفتن
ما
ظهر منها وما بطن
امين والحمد لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]